perfecto nada
de personas blancas tenían bloqueadas
en una situación muy compleja dado que
varios civiles armados empezaron a abrir
fuego
se denunciaron ataques vandálicos sobre
las casas y los conjuntos de personas
pero las páginas que cortan los drones
dan cuenta uno de unos camiones que no
corresponden a los vehículos en los que
siempre
le voy a pedir por favor que se aleje un
poco de la cámara para que lo podamos
ver bien y le voy preguntando mientras
tanto nosotros entendemos que usted fue
víctima de amenazas por parte de civiles
cómo fue eso
al momento de acercarme a registrar
para cubrir los supuestos de varios
manifestantes intentaron quitarme los
tipos de prensa y carnes de prensa le
tomaron fotografías un carnet hasta mi
número de identificación donde está el
nombre estatus y me declararon objetivo
militar
está la complejidad de éste
dado el hecho de utilizar mar
y seductores la decisión de cali en ese
momento si sabemos que está también en
el aeropuerto a punto de viajar hacia
bogotá le puede explicar por favor a la
audiencia por qué están tan caldeados
los ánimos en ese sector de la ciudad
particularmente que tan fundadas
son esas denuncias de los ciudadanos que
dicen estar secuestrados por los
bloqueos después de 12 días de paro
nacional
bueno
el concepto de secuestro es un concepto
muy elástico en este caso
en este contexto dado que si bien es
cierto que no se puede salir de la
ciudad con muchas vías pues el hecho de
que esté en el aeropuerto en este
momento existía de una manera de salir
de la ciudad ayer llegó una caravana de
abastecimiento gracias a un corredor
humanitario si hay una situación de
desabastecimiento de gasolina de algunos
bienes del mundo víveres pero hablar de
secuestro es llevar al extremo una
asociación
que se pueden presentar en muchas otras
ciudades del país donde hay bloqueos por
parte de grupos de ciudadanos
los ánimos están caldeados ex observados
no sólo por este hecho sino porque tiene
también un componente racial esto
escuchas los discursos los gritos de las
injurias y es a estas personas y tienen
un componente racial hay unas amenazas
de muerte por ser limpio por ser negro
allí hay un problema también de fora
fobia entonces
si ellos se sienten secuestrados pues es
muy interesante que gran parte de la
población caleña de sectores no tan
privilegiados no se sienta secuestrada a
pesar de que son los que no tienen
automóvil con los que no tienen la
capacidad monetaria para poder
abastecerse durante un largo periodo de
tiempo si tú hablas con vendedores
ambulantes hablas con personas de a pie
te van a decir que están con el pan lo
que no apoyan son los actos vandálicos
pero que están con el cambio y no puedes
ver las barricadas la gente es la que
los lleva les da una comida el estrés es
una situación bastante interesante y
bastante compleja bueno y ya para
finalizar para que usted pueda tomar su
vuelo con seguridad le quiero preguntar
qué es lo que pide la comunidad indígena
que participa en el paro y qué es lo que
puede ocurrir si siguen los bloqueos
bueno las comunidades indígenas del
norte del cauca han sido víctimas de
asesinatos sistemáticos y selectivo
desde hace muchos años entre muchas de
las reivindicaciones piden que se
cumplan los acuerdos que se han hecho
con el gobierno nacional
incontables veces en las movilizaciones
pero además está en cali acompañando a
los manifestantes y prestando una
garantía de un trato humanitario justo y
digno que es lo que siempre había
sucedido antes hasta este momento
también vale decir que la guardia
indígena que es como el grupo de control
que tiene que tienen estas comunidades
pues logró capturar a algunos policías
infiltrados en las manifestaciones logró
capturar a una persona que estaba
disparando en una camioneta blanca unos
días atrás sobre algunos puntos de
manipulación entonces eso eso eso eso
pone otra caja de complejidad en este
problema el alcalde de cali ayer señaló
que las comunidades indígenas no varían
tomarse atribuciones de autoridad y pues
los mensajes del presidente del ex
presidente uribe en twitter se desató
esta está esta ola de violencia sobre
las comunidades indígenas muchas gracias
a ustedes le deseo éxito en sus
cubrimiento si un regreso seguro a casa